We've mentioned earlier this week this recent
Fox news poll, which has been an absolute
treasure trove of interesting public opinion.
And one of the things that it found is that
54% of the country wants Donald Trump impeached.
50% wants Trump impeached and removed from
office.
On yesterday's show, I had video from Fox
and friends where Brian Kilmeade was stunned.
His word, not mine, that their own poll found
that half the country wants Donald Trump removed.
Now another one of the really interesting
things in this Fox news poll was the section
with policy questions where it asked, for
example, what do you think of Elizabeth Warren's
wealth tax?
What do you think about Donald Trump's us
Mexico border wall?
What do you think about Medicare for all?
And the Fox news poll found that the wealth
tax is way more popular with Americans than
Donald Trump's border wall.
68% of the country supports Elizabeth Warren's
wealth tax.
Only 44% of Americans support Donald Trump's
border wall.
The wealth tax is roughly 50% more popular
than the border wall.
55 ish percent more popular.
If you give people a choice between let's
tax really rich people or let's build a wall
on the us Mexico border, way more people want
to tax rich people then want to build this
wall.
The uh, uh, the, the, the sort of incongruency
is that if you look at media coverage, especially
on right wing media, they treat the wealth
tax like this absurd.
Supposedly socialist pipe dream while the
wall is treated as it's correct, it's obvious,
it's pragmatic, it's effective, it's just
a matter of getting Democrats to allow Donald
Trump the money he needs to build the wall.
So it's really important to understand that
media coverage of policy proposals and ideas
is not reflective number one of public opinion
about those policies, ideas of those policy
ideas and number two of the degree to which
the policies are feasible.
Uh, now it's important to also notice, I want
to be totally transparent here because I know
people will say, David, you've got to talk
about the results in the poll about Medicare
for all the same poll shows.
Medicare for all as described in the poll
is not that popular.
There's a question in this Fox news poll about
replacing the private health insurance system
that we have with a government run program.
It has only 41% support.
Now we know from experience that the wording
on that question really influences what people
say.
So on the one hand you can almost guarantee
low support for Medicare for all type system.
If you say something like, do you support
a government takeover of healthcare?
That wording will get a low level of support.
On the other hand, you can get off high level
of support for Medicare for all, if you phrase
it as should the government provide a basic
level of care to everyone regardless of ability
to pay, even though that's not exactly what
Medicare for all is, but the point is the
wording of these healthcare questions really
influenced the support.
Now, that being said, I want to tell everyone,
Fox news polls are considered pretty solid.
They are rated a by a number of different
organizations that rate pollsters including
five 38 this says nothing about Fox news TV
channel.
It says nothing about the content of Fox news
radio.
Their polling is considered relatively good
polling, so I do think we need to accept when
they say 68% favor a wealth tax, it's probably
close to that.
When they say only 41% support replacing private
insurance with a government run plant run
plan, it's probably close to that.
That doesn't mean that the question is asked
in the way that most clearly explains what
it is that's being proposed.
But that's part of the problem.
Part of the problem is the messaging and that
people don't understand what it is that's
being proposed.
It also, by the way, doesn't mean that a government
run program is bad.
All the poll tells us is that there's a long
way to go in garnering more public support.
And much of that lack of support certainly
comes from a lack of understanding of what
the proposals are and because of successful
smear campaigns against these programs.
But my message to you today is, unless we
recognize that we have a lot of work to do
to make Medicare for all more popular with
the public, we're going to have trouble implementing
it.
And by the way, I mean what, you know, the,
uh, the Obama era and the failure, despite
overwhelming public support to pass universal
background checks for firearm purchases, we
know that even with overwhelming public support,
it can be very difficult to actually make
policy happen and make things happen.
So it's an uphill battle.
It's a worthwhile one.
But in the meantime, uh, significantly more
support for Elizabeth Warren's wealth tax
than for Donald Trump's wall based on Fox
news, his own poll.
You won't hear much discussion of that on
Fox news as airwaves, but I encourage you
to look at the poll and look at these issue
by issue questions because the results are
very, very interesting.
Make sure you're following the David Pakman
show on Instagram at David Pakman show.
While you're there, follow me at David dot
Pacman.
Let's take a quick break.
We have another voter,
the cabinet [inaudible], Georgia.
That's time.
We'll talk about that after the grace